>>LaFawn Bailey: Hello everyone.
>>Audience: Hello.
[laughter]
>>LaFawn Bailey: I'm going to introduce Aisha
really quickly. I'm not gonna go too far into
her Bio because I really want us to have time
to have a unique conversation.
>>Aisha Tyler: Because it's very meager.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: And I don't know if you guys
have ever tried this, and I know that you've
already heard this joke, but you can Google
me.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: So. I don't know if you know
how to use it. We work here. We don't use
Google, c'mon.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: We just have it all in our
heads magically.
>>LaFawn Bailey: But the problem, people,
people think we are Google. That's the problem.
Ask us all kind of things.
>>Aisha Tyler: So we come to you and we're
like, so I need to get to 917 North 24th Street.
[laughter]
>>LaFawn Bailey: Exactly.
>>Aisha Tyler: If you could, if you could
drop a pin, that would be great.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: Search nearby for some restaurants.
That would be awesome too.
[laughter]
>>LaFawn Bailey: So that actually says more
that her Bio does.
[laughter]
>>LaFawn Bailey: But really quickly, she was
actually the first African-American and female
host on E!'s Talk Soup. I don't know how many
of you guys used to watch that.
[clapping and cheering]
>>LaFawn Bailey: But that was one of my favorite
shows.
[clapping]
>>LaFawn Bailey: After Talk Soup she moved
into television and film rolls. She was also
the first African-American to play an extended
character role on Friends.
[whooping and clapping]
>>LaFawn Bailey: Which I was really excited
about.
[clapping and laughing]
>>LaFawn Bailey: I think we were all really
exited about that. She played on the Ghost
Whisperer, CSI, 24, Nip/Tuck, Curb Your Enthusiasm,
Rio 911, The Boondocks and many, many more.
>>Aisha Tyler: So many more. Like three or
four more than that. Three or four.
[ laughter]
>>LaFawn Bailey: You wanna talk about those
three or four more?
>>Aisha Tyler: At least.
>>LaFawn Bailey: So, I'm gonna, I'm gonna
go back a little bit. Far back. Two years
ago. And talk about when you returned to your
stand-up roots.
>>Aisha Tyler: Yeah.
>>LaFawn Bailey: You created a, a DVD called
Aisha Tyler Is Lit.
>>Aisha Tyler: Yes.
>>Audience: Yeah.
>>LaFawn Bailey: Live at the Fillmore.
[laughter}
>>LaFawn Bailey: And you also wrote, directed
and starred in a viral Rap video.
>>Aisha Tyler: Um, hmmm.
>>LaFawn Bailey: Called Nowassitall.
>>Aisha Tyler: Um hmm.
>>LaFawn Bailey: Can we play that really quickly?
>>Aisha Tyler: Oh, we're gonna see it. That's
very exciting.
>>LaFawn Bailey: We're gonna see it.
>>[audience murmurs]
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: Oh, it's awesome. We're actually
going to the real internet.
[laughter]
[music begins] [coughing] [singing] Well let
me tell you my life story and how it came
to pass that I'm a fine black woman, but I
have no ass. When I was a little girl I was
the only black kid in my class. I was begging
and a pleading just to get a hall pass. Six
feet tall, sportin' at least three inches
of glass and even way back in the day I didn't
have much of an ass. I used to stumble 'round
the playground on size 12 feet, other kids
thought I was weird 'cause my family didn't
eat meat. They used to tease me out at recess
while I ate my pickled beets and all the black
girls in my hood would jump me out in the
street. You talk like a white girl. Oh my
God, I do not, that is so bogus. Shut up.
No, I don't got it but I want it. No ass at
all. If I was stuffed then I would flaunt
it. No ass at all. I turn around, it's kind
of funny, no ass at all. No ass at all. None.
Now I'm a grown black woman and I'm supposed
to act real hard and drive a pimped out Escalade
filled with pumped up body guards. And flash
my chocolate digits stacked with platinum
diamond rings, carry designer snake-skin bags
and have my orthodontia bling. But I'm really
not a pimp and I, I don't have any hoe and
when I drive my hybrid car, well, sometimes
I pick my nose. If you wanna fight me, well
then I'd probably have to say no. But get
me on an Xbox, I'll bust your ass on Halo.
I really can't rap, obviously my flow's completely
wack. I can't jump for jack, I'm really only
kind of half black. I use s-a-t words like
ohmahgosh, and checksum. If my street cred
came in dollars, I couldn't buy a pack of
gum. No, I don't have it, just a little, no
ass at all. And when I waggle, it don't wiggle,
no ass at all. My chocolate puddin' doesn't
jiggle, no ass at all. No ass at all. Born
and raised in San Francisco, that's the city
by the bay, and you don't really have to ask
me, yes, I have a friend that's gay. When
I go out with my crew we like to see a nice
movie, maybe get a super burrito from a chill
dude named Chuy . I like a nice plate of sushi
with a good bottle of wine. And I'm super
fond of onion bagels, yes, I think they're
mighty fine. If you need a mensch to help
you, I'm the kindest boss. I'm a bad ass shiksa
dipped in chocolate sauce. But I, I still
ain't got no onion booty, ain't no junk back
in my trunk, and if you ask me point blank,
I would admit, it's pretty bunk. If there
was a pillow or a cream to make my booty larger,
I'd try it, face it, my ship's more flat than
Angelina's on a diet. Ain't no shake come
with these fries, no ass at all. And when
I pass avert your eyes, no ass at all. My
ship been cut way down to size , no ass at
all. No ass at all. Damn. Now my badonka don't
realy donk. My lady lumps just ain't no fun,
I ain't got no buns hun, your anaconda won't
want none. There's no motor in the back of
my Honda, though I am a mocha fox. When white
boys check my back side, they say one word,
hmm lox . I was born a poor black girl and
I've had to bust my ass through strife . I'm
not complaining, I love comedy, I love my
family, I love my life. Though I'm grateful
to have made reality out many of my wishes.
One dream just won't come true, I wish I could
be more bootylicious. No, I don't have it,
just a little, no ass at all. And when I waggle,
it don't wiggle, no ass at all. My chocolate
puddin' doesn't jiggle, no ass at all. No
ass at all. Damn. No, I don't have it, just
a little, no ass at all. And when I waggle,
it don't wiggle, no ass at all. My friends
are trying not to giggle, no ass at all. No
ass at all. Shit . [music ends]
[clapping and cheering]
>>LaFawn Bailey: That was an exciting video.
>>Aisha Tyler: I was so excited that the internet
worked, wow!
[laughter]
>>LaFawn Bailey: So were we.
>>LaFawn Bailey: As a native of the San Francisco
Bay area, I suffer from a similar disorder.
>>Aisha Tyler: Yes.
>>LaFawn Bailey: It's not that bad, but I
definitely can't compete
>>Aisha Tyler: Nothing can be as bad as mine.
>>LaFawn Bailey: with some of the audience,
so. Tell us why you made that video and what
messages you hoped to convey.
>>Aisha Tyler: Oh, wow, so heady so early
in a conversation.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: Um, I had some money left over
from making my comedy special and I just was
I was just tired of hookers and blow and thought
I would spend it in some other way. No. Here's
why.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: I mean, I am in the entertainment
business. You know, I grew up here and I was
born in the city, but I spent a good amount
of time in the east bay and I was often, for
most of my childhood and probably until about
sophomore year in high school, the only, or
one of two or three black people in my school.
And, um, so I was kind of an outsider in that
I went to an all-white school and I lived
in a black neighborhood. And the kids in my
school didn't really particularly relate to
me and the girls in my neighborhood, you've
already seen how they felt about me, and so,
uh, I always had to kind of explain myself
and articulate who I was and I really, when
I was younger, it was really, uh, you know,
I was definitely in a lot of ways socially
odd and a little bit of a pariah. I was a
loner and I was a big reader. My parents didn't
believe in television, so there's pretty much
no better combination for being really, really
popular and cool than being a six feet tall,
only black, vegetarian kid in your school
who doesn't have a TV. That's good.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: I was like, hey, you guys wanna
read together?
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: Could do some middle earth
discussions. Silmarillion anybody? Anybody?
Uh, so.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: It, but over time it became
like a, like my red badge of courage. I'm
a weird kid and I'm proud of how different
I am and it also was a little bit of a manifesto.
I wanted to kind of, this was my first special,
and I wanted to tell my story, and tell it
first, so I didn't have to tell it inside
the show. I wanted to be able to talk about
other things. But when I first started doing
stand up and I would get up in front of a
crowd, I had to spend five minutes being like,
this is why I talk like this, this is why
I act like this, you know. This is who I am
and getting people to kind of come along because
you know I think for better or worse the explosion
of comedy and the explosion of diversity in
comedy has given rise to a lot of really great
things and then one of the negative things
is that people really want to categorize you.
If you're a black comic, you talk about these
things. If you're a female comic, you talk
about these things. And I don't do any of
that and people would, I'd get up and they'd
be like, what in the world is wrong with that
momma right here? You know and ah.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: You know, I just didn't want
to have to, I just wanted to, to just do the
manifesto at the top of the show so that I
could just get into other ideas and other,
and other concepts. And we did it, you know,
the comedy special, the way that it happened
was I got a deal with a company where they
were like, here's how much money you have
to spend and you can spend it any way you
want, and, um, I thought, again, hookers and
blow, ahhhhhh, ohhhhhh, 50-50. Um.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: But I thought instead of paying
a producer, I'll produce this whole thing
myself and use the extra money to add some
value, add some creative value and so, when
we were gonna do this, Comedy Central's like,
nobody likes music videos, people always change
the channel the minute they come on, no one's
gonna watch this. And we had, we had like
we opened, my show played after a Chris Rock
rerun and like had the highest number after
any Chris Rock show, you know. Usually people
watch Chris Rock and then, I don't know, run
off to just, I don't know, I don't know what
people do after they watch Chris.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: Run into the streets, scream,
take their clothes off, you know. Chris makes
me feel awesome and crazy, but everybody stayed
and and and the video's been really popular
and it was great. It was a nice thing to be
able to have something that I had written
and I directed it, produced it, I edited it.
I cut it. I posted it. I did everything. So
it was also a great creative process for me.
Yeah, it was really fun.
>>LaFawn Bailey: Congratulations on that.
[clapping]
>>Aisha Tyler: Thank you. Thank you. It looks
way. We shot it in HD by the way. That was
not really the best version that you could
have seen it. Grainy pop up ads for Lady Gaga
videos, but whatever.
[laughter]
>>LaFawn Bailey: You guys can can look up
the HD version as well online.
>>Aisha Tyler: Yeah.
>>LaFawn Bailey: Let's talk about your podcast.
>>Aisha Tyler: Oh yeah, let's talk about my
podcast.
>>LaFawn Bailey: Podcast. Girl on Guy with
Aisha Tyler.
>>Aisha Tyler: Yeah.
>>LaFawn Bailey: It's a show about stuff guys
love, brought to you by the ultimate guy's
girl
>>Aisha Tyler: I didn't write that.
>>LaFawn Bailey: Well, somebody did. I don't,
I don't
>>Aisha Tyler: I might have written it under
a pen name.
>>LaFawn Bailey: It kind of
[laughter]
>>LaFawn Bailey: Sounded like you maybe.
>>LaFawn Bailey: Video games, action movies,
drinking, comic books, sex, blowing shit up,
all of that good stuff. And it is already
the top downloaded pod, one of the top downloaded
podcasts on iTunes and Zune .
>>Aisha Tyler: Yeah, yeah, it's doing really
well. Yeah, it's only five, it debuted, uh,
I don't really know how this happened. I'm
waiting for a shoe, I'm waiting for whatever
the other shoe is to drop, just the devil
just
>>LaFawn Bailey: Which shoe?
>>Aisha Tyler: the demon at my doorstep. You
know, just like
>>LaFawn Bailey: Big shoe?
>>Aisha Tyler: The show it's had, we've had
five episodes. I thought, I'm gonna do this
for a year or two and then hopefully it'll
catch on. It debuted at number four out of
all comedy podcasts and it pretty much is
hovering between, it was at number one for
a little while. We kind of, here's what happens.
Your show downloads on a Tuesday, it goes
to number one, then that guy's show downloads
on a Wednesday and then it goes to number
one. So we're in this kind of pitched battle
for nothing by the way, I don't know if you
know this.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: Podcasts are free.
>>Aisha Tyler: So, we're in a pitch battle
for who can spend more of their own money
on shit for other people.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: But, um, but it is nice because
it's, I'm the only woman in the top ten comedy
list and that's really gratifying and I'm
really proud of the show and people are responding
to it really nicely. I mean, this is again
something where I had an idea for a show.
Shall I tell my whole life story?
>>LaFawn Bailey: Please.
>>Aisha Tyler: I was born a poor black child.
Um, no. What it is is that we were talking
about this. My parents divorced when they
were kind of young. And this is, you know,
the kind of the, the divorce battle over kids,
that's something that rich people do. I don't
know if you've noticed that.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: It's the rich people that are
like, you know, you can't have the children
until you give me the third car, you know.
Poor people are like, you don't have any money,
I don't have any money, just take one. Which
one do you want?
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: If I can buy groceries, I'll
buy them. If you can buy them, you buy them.
I don't, I can't even afford this phone conversation
right now.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: So, my parents, my mom got
my sister and my dad took me and I just was
raised by a single dad. And he was a great
guy and a really attentive, really loving
dad, but he was a guy. And so I had this very
guy-oriented childhood. My dad took me, the
first movie he took me to see was Road Warrior,
which is really
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: Great entertaining, just like
for an eight or nine year old girl. That's
a good, that's a good. Daddy, they ripped
they guys hand off with a chain, why? Wanna
sleep with the light on? I don't wanna sleep
ever again, that's what I don't want. And
my dad didn't even have a car, we didn't have
a car until I was in high school, so I grew
up on the back of a motorcycle and my dad
actually had to build this harness, he had
a custom-built harness to hold me on the bike,
'cause I was such a nerd I would read on his
back. And then I'm like, what's gonna happen
with Frodo and Bilbo? And I would sort of
start to fly off.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: So, um, sort of to keep me
from death by science fiction, he had to,
he had, he had this thing he would strap me
to his back so I could read on his back. So,
I just had this really, really like dude-like
childhood. Also, like, you know, like dads
have this really simplistic approach to day
care. I mean now, it's nowadays where we're
like, you know, little Billy's allergic to
peanuts, and, ah, well he's not allergic,
he just doesn't like them and he gets hyper
when he eats them and no television if it's
not Charlie Rose.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: You know back then my dad was
like, "Look, I have a date. I'm dropping you
off at the arcade with $20 in quarters. Don't
talk to strangers." That was how it was.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: I grew up on video games. I'm
a huge gamer. I played. I was like a big defender.
I was a huge defender. We had the Defender
game across the street in the Laundromat from
my house. And that, I just would wear that
shit out. And just, and just the push all
buttons and just rahhhh, you know I'm like,
tinier kids would come in and I'd go like,
you're not getting on this game until you're
like 11, so just get out of here, leave now.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: So I was just a huge gamer.
And I just wanted to do, I was, I wanted to
do a show that was about the stuff that I
was into and when I would talk to people about
doing it as a TV show, they would go, ahh,
boys aren't gonna, boys aren't gonna watch
a girl talk about guy stuff, you know. You
know unless you're gonna take your shirt off.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: Sure, guys wanna hear you talk
with your shirt off, that's what they want.
OK. So at every strip club they're like, I'd
like to play $20 so we could talk about raising
the debt ceiling; that would be great. If
you could sit on my lap while we discuss world
politics, that would be really
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: So, uh, I just said I'm gonna
make this show. And I just made the show.
And, and, and people really love it and I
think it has a different, it feels different
than a lot of other podcasts in that it's
a one-on-one conversation, not just with men.
It's, it's, it's about guy stuff, but I do
have women on the show as well and I talk
with a lot of female comedians because probably
95 percent of our time we're the only woman
in the work context that we're in and its,
I've been to comedy clubs where I look at
their calendar for the year and there are
51 weeks of guys and me. So we have a very
specific kind of life and I just wanted to
make a show that came from the perspective
and it's been great and people love it because
they get to come on and talk about their lives
and not talk about their work. I mean, I think
you do 30 interviews about a project and it's
just refreshing to sit down and just talk
about who you are and how you got to where
you are right now, so. And we curse a lot.
Whee. There's no FCC in the interwebs.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: So it's great.
>>LaFawn Bailey: Wonderful. Speaking of video
games.
>>Aisha Tyler: Uh huh.
>>LaFawn Bailey: I saw in the interview that
you actually play a voice in Halo Reach.
>>Aisha Tyler: Uh huh, uh huh.
>>LaFawn Bailey: How many of you guys play
Halo?
>>Aisha Tyler: Anybody play Halo? Anybody
heard of Halo? Anybody?
>>LaFawn Bailey: I'm pretty sure that there's
somebody that plays Halo.
>>Aisha Tyler: Anybody ever break a bone and
have to wear a halo?
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: Yeah, I'm a huge, Halo was
probably my gateway drug back into gaming.
I stopped playing for a long time and then
I started playing the first Halo game and
uh, I don't even remember that year. I think
I blacked out, really, just.
[laughter]
>>LaFawn Bailey: Really? [chuckling]
>>Aisha Tyler: It's really, it's really sad
to be a grown woman with a mortgage and be
up at 4:00 on a Tuesday trying to kill digital
aliens. That's just
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: That makes you want to reconsider
your whole, all your life choices up to that
point.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: But I will say, you guys are
all here safe and sound right now 'cause of
shit I did on Halo last night. That's all
I'm saying.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: I save the universe every day
so you can come here and eat organic nut things.
[laughter]
>>LaFawn Bailey: And you're preparing for
the zombie invasion?
>>Aisha Tyler: I am ready for the zombie apocalypse
by the way, fully prepared. If it goes down,
I've got crossbows. I'm ready to go. I've
got a sawed-off. I got a hammer.
>>LaFawn Bailey: That's what I'm talking about.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: Sometimes you need a hammer.
Sometimes you want to kill a zombie with no
noise.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: There are times, there are
times when it, that call for silence, you
know what I mean, and that's when a hammer
comes in very handy.
>>LaFawn Bailey: Very nice.
>>Aisha Tyler: The zombies are dumb, but they're
also slow, and that what's great about zombies.
I prefer a zombie apocalypse to an alien invasion
if we had to get into it, I think. Aliens,
all, they seem fast, right? How come they
never an alien movie about like blobs coming
down and just.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: Like you're just like, there's
aliens! And they're just like, yeah, we're
here. We're gonna, we're gonna fuck you up
at some point.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: Really like a four-hour movie.
>>LaFawn Bailey: Maybe not as exciting, I
don't know.
>>Aisha Tyler: Not so exciting. We're just
like, we're like, what's that new coffee table?
It's an alien. They don't move very quickly.
A year is like 4,000 of our years.
>>LaFawn Bailey: We should be ready for them
with your hammer.
>>Aisha Tyler: We've got plenty of time. We've
got plenty of time. Yeah, and then we'll hit
'em with a hammer.
>>LaFawn Bailey: Awesome.
[laughter]
>>LaFawn Bailey: Another project you have
is that you are currently a voice as the super
sexy spy Lana Kane.
>>Aisha Tyler: Yeah.
>>LaFawn Bailey: On Archer.
>>Aisha Tyler: Archer. Yeah. I love that show
so much.
>>LaFawn Bailey: Which is the highest rated
show in FX history. Which is pretty awesome.
>>Aisha Tyler: It's pretty exciting.
>>LaFawn Bailey: You have, you've had a lot
of firsts.
>>Aisha Tyler: I've had a lot of firsts.
>>LaFawn Bailey: First woman, first African
American, it's all wonderful.
>>Aisha Tyler: I don't really know how it
happened. I don't know, do any of you guys
listen to the Nerdist podcast? Anybody here?
Anybody?
>>LaFawn Bailey: There was a hand back there.
>>Aisha Tyler: Nice. I, I, I don't wanna be,
I don't wanna be, I don't wanna state the
obvious, but I'm confused that there's one
guy at Google who's heard of the Nerdist podcast.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: Scary.
>>LaFawn Bailey: There's one guy that admitted
it, but there's many more in the audience.
>>Aisha Tyler: Oh. It's OK. You guys are cooler
than I expected. It's awesome. We're into
the sex and guns podcast, bitches. Bam!. Um,
so, ah, but Chris, Chris was, Chris just sent
me an e-mail and he was like, he was like
took a picture, you know a little screen grab
of my show at number one on iTunes and he
said, "Look at you." And I said, "I have no
idea how this happened." And I really don't.
I have no idea how all these firsts happened.
I did it. I'm not running around thinking
that I'm gonna be a trailblazer. I think,
um, I'm just trying to do stuff that I'm interested
in and that I'm excited about and that feel
compelling to me. You know, I think the entertainment
business is shot through with originality,
um, [audience laughs] and, uh, yes, driven,
just driven by the, by a desire to be new
and different. And I just, I just, I just
felt like I wanted to find a way to be excited
every time when I got up from work. You know
this business, people always go, "Well, how
do you pick your projects? How do you choose,
you know, these original things? How did you
become such a ground breaker?" I'm like, look,
the person who can say yes to jobs is Tom
Cruise. That's the guy whose like, "I'd like
to do this." The rest of us are like, "Please,
sir, may I have some more? I'm so hungry.
I'd like to make enough to make my SAG minimum
for health insurance this year, please."
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: "I'll be on, I'll be an extra
on Jersey Shore. Please, so hungry." So I
don't know that I've chosen to be a ground
breaker, I've just been lucky. Um, and, that
some things have come along that have been
interesting and exciting. I've said no to
some things. I've said no to some things that
I thought might not be the best use of my
talent. You know. But, but I don't know how,
I don't know how that happened. You know,
I just, Friends was, I didn't think, like,
I'm gonna go be the first black girl on Friends,
I'd made a little flag, you know, yeah, here
we go everybody, you know?
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: It's not like that at all.
>>LaFawn Bailey: We all did that, though.
We celebrated.
>>Aisha Tyler: Yeah, right. Yeah, I mean,
afterwards you kind of look back and you look
at whatever it is, you're just trying to do
good work and then you look back and you see
that maybe the assembled body of the work
that you've created is, is bigger than the
sum of any one part that you know that you
were making at the time. Um. That was a show
that I was a fan of and, uh, and I went and
I auditioned for it and the reason I think,
one of the big reasons I think I got it was
because I had seen every episode of Friends
when I went in there, you know? So I knew,
I was like I know what, I know what these
guys want, you know? But it wasn't like I
thought I'm gonna change the world. And it
wasn't a role that was written for an African
American actress. I auditioned, yeah, no,
it wasn't written African American, not in
the text, they auditioned, it was me, three
other Caucasian actresses and an Asian actress.
I mean it was, they were just looking for
the right person and with, with Archer, again,
it was like I got this script. It was an amazing
script for a tiny show that I was sure nobody
was ever gonna see.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: Mainly 'cause I got to say
the word ballslappiest in the pilot.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: I was like this is not getting
on television. Does anybody? Anybody? You
guys have like a standards and practices group?
And we still feel that way. You know we went
to Comic-Con last year with a show and it
was a room of about this many people and then
we went there this year and it was an airplane
hanger of people. And it was so exciting and
it wasn't like, "We're so awesome." It was
like, if this is all the people that ever
watch our show, this is plenty, this is so
great, you know.
[laughter}
>>Aisha Tyler: Um, this is enough. I'm happy
now. So I just, I, I, you know I also feel
like having been such a weird kid and such
a kind of an outsider my whole life, I'm very
comfortable being in that place and I think
if you're comfortable being an outsider and
you embrace it, the likelihood is much higher
that you're gonna make work to please yourself
and not other people and therefore that work
will stand out and, and will be compelling,
you know. I don't, I don't wanna be everybody's
friend, I just wanna be all the weird kids'
friends. You know. They're just.
>>LaFawn Bailey: You're at Google, so.
>>Aisha Tyler: Yeah, sweet. It's a whole campus
full of weird kids.
>>LaFawn Bailey: Exactly.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: Who by the way, I tell people
now, you know, like they would say what would
you say to like the teenage you or what would
you say to kids like you? And I'm like, you
know, and this is not my idea, this is an
old saw, but all the kids I went to with,
like hung out with in high school or saw in
high school that were like hot, and they were
having sex. Who has sex in high school? Who
has sex in college?
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: Who has sex in their 20's?
No, um,
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: All the kids that were super
cool in high school, like popular and good
looking, like, they never had to try. You
know what I mean? They never had to try to
fit in. They never had to try to be smart
or be funny. They never had to try to make
their ideas heard. It just was very easy for
them. Their life was very much a lay up. And
those are the people that when they get out
in the real world, it's very, very difficult
for them. You know? They, they just everything
feels very easy and for the kids that really
struggle, that really, you know, felt like,
there's only, there's nobody like me, those
are the kids that strike out and they do original
things and they do, you know and they do stuff
like, uh, Google, and they create new ideas
and they create new businesses because you
know they don't, they feel like no one's gonna
like this. Well, no one already likes me.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: You know what I mean? You know?
>>Aisha Tyler: I'm good with the pariah shit.
It's OK. You know, so.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: As they eat their Ramen noodles.
>>Aisha Tyler: In the corner. Uh, so, so for
me it's just been, I'm really trying. And
now maybe there's a part of me that feels
like, like there's this you know there's a
community online of different kinds of people
that have come up now around the stuff that
I've done or that are excited about the stuff
that I've done. Like I wanna make it cool
for, uh, for little, for little girls to like
stuff that no little girls shouldn't like.
And I wanna make it cool for little kids who
are you know not white to like stuff that
like not-white kids aren't supposed to like.
Like I listened to punk rock and I skated
and I, and you know I listened to heavy metal
when I was in high school, mainly 'cause I
was sick of people telling me, "Black kids
don't skate and black kids don't like heavy
metal. And black." It was like, go shove it!
I'm gonna set this on fire and then I'm gonna
shove it for you.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: You know I just hated that.
I hated being told what I need, what I should,
should do and how to fit in. So for me I just,
I want it to be OK to be weird, to be a weird
kid, you know, and also to be a really weird
adult. I think you that you know that's good.
>>LaFawn Bailey: I think you've accomplished
that.
>>Aisha Tyler: To embrace your weirdness,
yeah.
>>LaFawn Bailey: I think you've accomplished
that.
>>Aisha Tyler: What's that? Have I accomplished
that?
>>LaFawn Bailey: I think so.
>>Aisha Tyler: Well, I'm really weird.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: I know that part. Yeah, I'm
OK with that. Yeah. And now I just, it's just
too late. You just get to a point in your
life you say no really, I'm so tired, I'm
just so tired. I could try to change, but
I, bad, Breaking Bad is coming on. I'll change
in a week or two, I just. I've gotta go back
and watch all of Game of Thrones again. Then
I'll change. I'll change after that. Yeah.
>>LaFawn Bailey: I love that show.
>>Aisha Tyler: Oh, God. Ned, why did they
do it to Ned? Oh my God. There's the best
YouTube video. OK. So here's a good example
of this.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: First let me say that Aahhhh!
[squeals]
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: That was 8-year old Aisha coming
out.
>>LaFawn Bailey: You got a little exited.
You got a little excited. It's fine.
>>Aisha Tyler: I get so excited about Game
of Thrones; I'm gonna start crying.
>>LaFawn Bailey: It's OK. It's alright.
>>Aisha Tyler: So, um, Game of Thrones made
me so crazy. And, it was all I could think
about, talk about, anybody else? Nobody? And
uh the second to last episode, does anyone,
I don't want to. Spoiler alert. Um, if you,
if you were in a like a worm hole up until
then, yeah, cover your ears. If you haven't
seen it, leave the room. You do know you can
download it on the internet. So um and also
this isn't in my joke but like the whole thing
where I like posted something about it like
four days after the second-to-last episode
happened, so I'm like Aisha spoiler alert.
I was like there's already a spoiler out there
it's called the book. But. Is my mic off?
Is it off?
>>LaFawn Bailey: We'll switch. Here.
>>Aisha Tyler: I broke it.
>>LaFawn Bailey: Switch.
[laughter]
[taps mic]
>>Aisha Tyler: OK good. So, um, so uh, so
the second-to-last episode something very
terrible happens to Ed Stark and ah, and then
like we were there was like this five minute
thing in the, in the, on the couch where you
just stared at the TV like you couldn't believe
it, like you were just waiting for like magical
elves to come and be like, "No, he's not dead.
Do dah do dah do do." You know like Ewoks,
do dah do dah do jub jub. And um, and then
it was like it was so upsetting so why we
like mourned for a little while as nerds are
want to do and we went away, we played a little
Braid, a little bit of Portal 2 and we eased
through it. And um, there's this video on
the internet and it just shows you how diverse
kind of nerddom is now 'cause there, it's
this, this black guy, one of my people, and
he is so upset, he is so upset about, about
Ned dying and his friend is filming him and
the guy is going crazy. He's like, he's using,
he's using a specific word that my people
like to use occasionally. And ah, but I'm
not gonna use that word. He's just going,
"They killed my brother Ned, they killed my
brother Ned." And he's like, his friend's
like, "It's like somebody really died."
[Laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: It's the best thing. And he's
kicking things and I'm like, that's how I
feel right now. They killed Ned.
>>LaFawn Bailey: It's horrible.
>>Aisha Tyler: So yes. This, being a nerd
is very hard. We're just so much more emotional
than regular people, you know. We, suspension
of disbelief is not a joke with nerds, that's
what I'm saying.
[laughter]
>>LaFawn Bailey: Alright. You OK now?
>>Aisha Tyler: No, I'm not, I'm really not
OK now.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: I'm working through it, but
I'm not OK. No.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: Sweating. I knocked my chair
over.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: Just imagine that I was this
exact girl, this exact size, and I was eight.
That's
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: You can just. Yes. Why won't
anybody play with me?
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: It's pretty much how it was,
so
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: Thank you. That, I mean, that's
>>LaFawn Bailey: That's real nice.
>>Aisha Tyler: That's only mildly hyperbolic,
I want you to know. Alright.
[laughter]
>>LaFawn Bailey: I'm gonna wait for them to
calm down in the front over there.
[laughter]
>>LaFawn Bailey: Let's bring it down a little
bit.
>>Aisha Tyler: We can, can we? Can we bring
it down? Is it possible?
>>LaFawn Bailey: Let's bring it down a little
bit.
>>Aisha Tyler: I don't think so.
>>LaFawn Bailey: And talk about how you're
also an author.
>>Aisha Tyler: I am an author. I wrote a book.
>>LaFawn Bailey: You're a contributor to Glamour
magazine. You write about the media's unrealistic
portrayal of feminine beauty.
>>Aisha Tyler: I do that.
>>LaFawn Bailey: You're a comedic columnist
for the Entertainment Weekly and you wrote
a book called Swerve: Reckless Observations
of a Post-Modern Girl.
>>Aisha Tyler: Um, hum.
>>LaFawn Bailey: Could you please tell us
what that's about?
>>Aisha Tyler: I don't know.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: Um, you know, I ah, I, yes,
I, I wanted to write. The reason the book
came about was because I was doing these stand
up shows and my stand up was very much like
a conversation, it's not like a series of
jokes. I just kind of talk with the audience
and I really want it to feel like we're having
a conversation as a, as a group. But what
happened is that we'd have these great conversations
with fans after the show and, and they were
in much more long form and more sprawling
and I just wanted to have that kind of conversation
with people in, about things that I knew I
wasn't gonna be able to really fit into a
like the one-hour show that I do. So I, I,
it was, it's a, and also at the time I think
I had just read Chuck Klosterman's first book,
Sex, Drugs and Cocoa Puffs, which is the best
book ever. Oh my God, if you haven't read
it, you have it read it right now. He's like
so amazing. 'Cause he kind of does, he's one
of these people that kind of synthesizes,
kind of socio-cultural analysis and like big-thinking
ideas with like really, really low culture
stuff. You know what I mean? And, ah, you
know, so he's just, there's like, you know
this stuff about serial killers and stuff
about cereal, you know what I mean, in the
same book. And, um.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: And it's almost, almost rhyming.
And uh, so I just, I loved that and I wanted
to write a book that was in that vein, so
Swerve is a, is a collection of essays about
popular culture from my point of view and
there is some kind of, it's not a how-to book,
it's not a self-help book, it's not an autobiography.
It's really just kind of the same socio-cultural
analysis that I do. I sound so much smarter
than I am. Learn like five big words, just
sprinkle them liberally throughout a conversation.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: That I do in my act which is
just talking about who we are as a culture
and how we see things as a culture and kind
of turning it on its head. So, ah, but it's
everything from talking about, God I don't
even have, the book is here somewhere, but
everything from using the Art of War as a
dating manual, to um
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: Yes. It's really effective.
>>LaFawn Bailey: You want to elaborate on
that one?
>>Aisha Tyler: Either you're gonna get laid
or somebody's gonna die. One or the other.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: Um, siege techniques very good
when trying to pick up on a guy or a girl.
Um, and ah, and also just about like the kind
of the rise of the music video and the music
video culture and what that's doing to the
way that we see ourselves and the way that
we relate to each other. But they're all funny.
They're all funny essays and there's a lot
of drinking stories in there. I'm a comedian,
so it's all gonna end with drinking at some
point. Because we get booze for free. Uh huh.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: I don't know if you knew that
about our job. In the beginning they just
pay you in chicken wings and lite beer, that's
just, you know, yeah.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: A classy way to make a living.
>>LaFawn Bailey: Very classy. Um, if we have
any live questions in the room, go ahead and
line up at the mic. In the meantime, I'm going
to ask a question from our dory page.
>>Aisha Tyler: From who?
>>LaFawn Bailey: Our dory page.
>>Aisha Tyler: Your what page?
>>LaFawn Bailey: That's our internal tool.
You can see the questions up there. So those
are people that submitted questions online.
>>Aisha Tyler: OK, what did you call it?
>>LaFawn Bailey: Dory.
>>Aisha Tyler: Dory. What is that? Is that
an acronym?
>>LaFawn Bailey: We name our tools stuff.
>>Aisha Tyler: Like a person, like the fish?
>>LaFawn Bailey: Yeah. Like Nemo.
>>Aisha Tyler: You guys have a lot of time
on your hands here at Google.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: Alright. I'm ready.
>>LaFawn Bailey: You ready?
>>Aisha Tyler: Yeah, I'm ready. Let's do it.
>>LaFawn Bailey: Alright. What good versus
bad advice have you been given about how to
succeed as a woman, a woman of color in the
industry? Who have been your best mentors?
>>Aisha Tyler: Oooohhhhhh. Uh, wow, OK. I
will say, the, the. I'm gonna answer that
in two parts, the second part first. Uh, my
best mentors have been my parents, and specifically
my father. Um, my dad grew up in Pittsburgh,
which wasn't really a hoppin' town back then
and hasn't really improved much since then.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: And, ah, Detroit looks at Pittsburgh,
and goes man, you gotta get your shit together.
And uh
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: And, but and he was in a family
with, his dad died when he was very young
and he was the only man, four sisters and
his mom, and just, you know, in poverty, and
didn't make it past the eighth grade and was,
you know, had to really struggle when he was
a teenager and then just completely remade
his life. And my father is such an optimist.
He's not a Pollyanna, you know, he's not,
he's not like an idealist. He is somebody
who just doesn't quit. And what that translates
to when you're a little kid is, "I know you
broke your arm, suck that shit up." But, ah
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: What it translates to as an
adult is that you're the architect of your
own destiny and you can do anything that you
wanna do. And my dad would he had a lot of
he's a big aphorism guy, he's got a lot of
sayings. I don't know, do dads go to a class
when there like, you know what I mean? Like
your wife is pregnant, there's like a secret,
OK you gotta come up with some sayings. We're
gonna pitch some stuff out today. But my dad
had a lot. His favorite was, "Keep your grades
and you drawers up." That was his favorite
one.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: Classic. It holds up even to
this day, really right? So.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: And he would give me a big
speech when I would leave the house and it
had along the lines of, "What are you gonna
do today?" And I'd have to go, he'd say, "Whose
day is it." And I'd say, "It's my day." And
then he'd say, "What are you gonna do?" And
I'd say, "Grab it by the balls." Uh, so.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: Again super appropriate when
you're eight.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: So. And we always joked that
my father is such a forward-looking person
that if his house was on fire, he would go
get marshmallows and a stick. Do you know
what I mean?
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: He's that guy. He just cannot
be, he cannot be defeated, you know? And so,
he's probably my biggest mentor. In the business,
I would love to say, I would love to say that
there have been women who have mentored me,
but there, it's mostly been men. I, assuming
they were all trying to sleep with me.
[laughter]
>>LaFawn Bailey: Most likely.
>>Aisha Tyler: Most likely. Oh, they lost
out big time. Ha ha. Who won? Me!
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: No, you know, mainly because
comedy is dominated by men. I've had women
who've been really good friends and good supporters.
But when I was looking forward it was mostly
guys and a couple of comedians that really
I remember vividly a comedian named Tom Rhodes,
who I don't think he's a bay area native,
but he's lived here for a long time and he's
incredibly smart and incredibly funny and
would let me come and do like a guest set,
which is where you go to their show and do
a few minutes on their show and he was just
incredibly, like you know, encouraging. I
remember going to him once and I was like,
"Well, just tell me what to do, like to be
like you? Like how do I get to where you are?"
And he's like, you just gotta keep getting
on the stage. And I was like, "You just don't
want me to know." You know.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: But, you know, it was true.
It was just like an athlete. You know the
way you win races is by running races and,
um, so he was incredibly helpful. George Lopez
has been really, really kind to me over the
years. And, yeah, I mean, you know, this is
a self-starting business, comedy. It's not
like a business where you get a job and you
work and you build up equity and a reputation
and you move forward and unless you touch
somebody on the boobs inappropriately or set
your desk on fire, you're gonna move forward.
You know what I mean? My job is a job where
you can be the CEO, and then be fired and
be the assistant, and then be the CEO again
and be fired and be assistant, then be the
CEO a third time and then, and then flame
out miserably because you wrote a check to
a whore in Las Vegas for $30,000. I don't
know who that is. Who did that?
[laughter]
>>LaFawn Bailey: You know who that is.
>>Aisha Tyler: Yeah, Charlie Sheen. So, um.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: It's not a meritocracy, my
business at all. That doesn't that mean hard
work isn't valuable, but it's not what, a
lot of times talented, hard-working people
don't get ahead, and awful, terrible, half-naked
drunks get a fourth season of their show on
MTV. Who could that be? Jersey Shore. So,
uh.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: You have to, you have to believe
in yourself. And be unwavering in your belief
that you have something to contribute. And
there aren't a lot of people, not that they're
selfish, but they're just, it's such a every
man and woman for themselves kind of a business
that it's rare for someone to kind of take
you under their wing. You mostly, it's more
of a foxhole mentality. Like we're all, people
are always like, hey, get my movie made. I'm
like, dude I can't get my movie made, so,
um, you know, I'll take you out to lunch.
So we do a lot of, there's a lot of kind of
like, you know what I mean, lateral collaboration
I think in my business, yeah.
>>LaFawn Bailey: Very nice. OK. Do we have
a question?
>>Female audience member #1: Hi, Aisha, my
name's Belinda.
>>Aisha Tyler: Hi, Belinda.
>>Female audience member #1: It's a pleasure
to meet you, for.
>>Aisha Tyler: Thank you.
>>Female audience member #1: I have a statement.
It's very quick because I know a lot of people
have questions, but I first noticed you when
you were hosting Talk Soup and you immediately
jumped out at me because I saw my daughter
in you. My daughter is a, is a theater major
and she's been interested in performing arts
for, you know, from year one, from her birth.
And, you know, and I've always used you as
a role model for her and it's like, look at
Aisha Tyler. And the reason why is because
she's grown up here in the bay area. She's
sort of the outsider. Doesn't fit into the
stereotypes of black females or in particularly
in her direction in performing arts. So basically
I just wanted to quickly say thank you for
being true to yourself and you know, because
it means so much for other people who also
want to be true to themselves. So thank you
very much.
>>Aisha Tyler: That's really kind. Thank you
so much.
[clapping]
>>Male audience member #1: Uh.
>>Aisha Tyler: I wonder if you play video
games?
[laughter]
>>Male audience member #1: A little, a little
Halo.
>>Aisha Tyler: A little bit? OK.
[laughter]
>>Male audience member #1: So I just wanna
know what's going on with season three, Archer?
If you have any comments for if it's gonna
stay like as, as good, if it's, you know.
>>Aisha Tyler: Is it gonna stay as, is it
gonna suck? Is that your question?
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: Please don't suck. Um, well
we're working on season three right now. And
it's gonna be friggin' awesome. And it's,
yes, it's gonna be great. Our show is, I don't,
I am just a happy, like, bus rider on our
show. The guy who created it, Adam Reed, is
a genius. He writes amazing scripts. He writes
the entire show by himself. When we got our
second season order, they were like, "Hey,
now you're a big man, you can hire you know
oompa loompas to write the show." You know?
And no one can, no one could really write
the show the way that Adam wrote it, so now
Adam writes everything, which I'm sure he
really regrets, except for when he's lying
on a big bag of money.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: So, but it's. He's amazing.
>>Male audience member #1: So are you, are
you just the voice then?
>>Aisha Tyler: I'm just the voice. Here's
how the show works. He writes an amazing script.
>>Male audience member #1: So you're not just.
>>Aisha Tyler: I'm just the voice.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: I also sweep up.
>>Aisha Tyler: [laughing] It's OK. Adam writes
these amazing scripts and then it's, we get
in the room and we each record our parts completely
separate from each other. But what we do a
lot of is say it a million times, say it this
way, say it that way, add this word, change
that word, now go nuts. So we do a lot of
ad-libbing in the, and they animate to what
we've recorded. So we do a lot of ad-libbing
in the recording process. And a lot of things
that we've said in casual conversation end
up in following episodes because it's really,
we're a comedy troupe, you know, and we've
really started to figure out each other's
tempo and voice, so. But I, but I wish I could
take credit for the show. If I could, I guarantee
you I would. But we're doing, it's a, it's
a larger season this season. We had 13 episodes
last season, it's gonna be 16 this season.
So, yeah, yeah, yeah, you gotta check it out.
[clapping]
>>Aisha Tyler: The first episode airs September
15. Yeah.
>>Male audience member #1: Cool, thanks.
>>LaFawn Bailey: Very nice
>>Aisha Tyler: Hi.
>>Female audience member #2: Hi, um, hi, I'm
Jana. I actually just graduated from Dartmouth.
>>Aisha Tyler: Oh my God, that's awesome.
[clapping]
>>Female audience member #2: I brought this,
it's probably a six out of ten on the tacky
scale, but I brought it anyway.
>>Aisha Tyler: That's adorable, no it's like
a 10 on a 10 on the awesome scale.
[laughter]
>>Female audience member #2: Thank you. I
just wanted to know about your experience
at Dartmouth and how it impacted you. I just
came from there and so, it's an interesting
place to be sometimes as a black female, but
how it impacted you in your pursuit of your
career.
>>Aisha Tyler: I found my husband there.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: You know, not that I was planning
on getting married. God. Did you guys know
you have to that for, like, ever? Uh, wow.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: It's like, are you still here?
Really? OK. Nothing in the garage you want
to do?
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: [laughing] My husband and I
just had our 17th wedding anniversary. So,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
[clapping]
>>LaFawn Bailey: Congratulations.
>>Aisha Tyler: Yeah, I know. Thank you. In
Hollywood years it's like a double diamond
platinum.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: Ah, you know, I really loved
Dartmouth. But I will say this. You know I
grew up in a very progressive place, obviously
I grew up in the bay area, and Dartmouth,
when I went, was even more conservative than
it is now. It was infamous for conservatism.
It was right around the time of South African
divestment, and a lot of students were protesting
and they built like this big shantytown on
the green at Dartmouth and the really like
arch-conservative group of kids like sledgehammered
it down in the middle of the night and almost
killed somebody that was sleeping inside.
I mean it was a really intense place to go
to school. My high school counselor said,
"Don't got there, because you're gonna martyr
your college career." And then I said, "I'm
going to set this on fire and shove it up
your butt." And I went there immediately.
Yeah. So, um, don't ever tell me not what
to do. You know what I mean? I'll do it. Except
for if you tell me something stupid and then
I won't do it. I mean like. But I, I loved
it maybe because I was such an outsider, again
I really embrace that and I liked being so
different. I think I wore Birkenstocks for
the entire freshman year, through the winter,
by the way, that takes commitment. I'd like
the ugly wool socks, I was like, I'm a hippie,
ahhh, you know and just walk around with an
avocado in my hand, you know, who wants some
of this?
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: So, um, I, I really embraced
that my outsiderness and I made a point of
making a point. I think. But what I loved
about Dartmouth was that it's a smaller school
and I, you can really make a mark there, you
can really, it's a, you can be a big fish
in a small pond, and also I was a big snowboarder,
so I spent a lot of time snowboarding there.
Yeah, and I taught snowboarding. Dartmouth
has its own "mountain." And by mountain, I
mean that if you put some plywood off that
deck out there, pretty much replicate it here.
So, but I loved that part about it. I was
a founding member of the Rockappellas, so
I was really into singing. Yeah. I was a weird
kid, but it was a good place to be a weird
kid. You know, it's, sometimes it's nice to
go to a place where you where you're not quite
right in the middle of the bull's eye of the
main stream. You know what I mean? Because
you just are forced to look at yourself and
how you wanna make your life choices a little
bit harder. So I liked that. And I found my
people. I was in the Tabard. If you guys don't
know about the Tabard. One person knows about
the Tabard. OK. So, yes, the one from Canterbury
Tales. There was a fraternity, I'm telling
you all about stuff you didn't ask about.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: Just continuing a theme. The
Tabard was, the Tabard was formerly a fraternity
called Sigma Chi, which on the national level
is very, like intensely conservative, yeah,
very conservative. And in the, oh, it's gonna
get all political, whee. OK, so in the '70s
it was, you couldn't get into the fraternity
if you were black or Jewish and Dartmouth
told the fraternity, if you don't start admitting
Blacks and Jews, we're gonna kick you off
of campus. And they said, "We've never heard
of Blacks or Jews, what is this that you talk
about?"
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: So, then they nattied their
bow tie and strode away. So, uh.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: Dartmouth did kick them off
of campus and the result was that Sigma Chi
became the Tabard and it was just jam-packed
with Blacks and Jews. And women and hippies.
And it became this really liberal fraternity
that also had women, so it was a co-ed fraternity.
Nobody was having sex though. Hmmm. [laughter]
And it became like this kind of paragon of
progressivism and it was a really cool place
to join because if you weren't a big joiner
that was the place that you could join and
feel like you were a part of a group of people
that was like you. But it was very open, I
mean there were very conservative people in
the Tabard and very liberal people in the
Tabard and it was really a place that embraced
otherness. No matter who you were you could
be a part and there was no judgment and it
was a great, great place. It smelled like
feet though, let me tell you that right now.
So like.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: Hippies, not big on the hygiene.
Alright. [laughing] It's nice to meet you.
Did you like it there?
>>Female audience member #2: I loved it.
>>Aisha Tyler: Yeah, it's so great. Yeah,
it's awesome. A lot of drinking.
[laughter]
>>LaFawn Bailey: Alright, we'll take another
Dory question really quick.
>>Aisha Tyler: Oh, OK, a Dory question.
>>LaFawn Bailey: You've taken on Ann Coulter.
Who else would you like to debate?
>>Aisha Tyler: Oh, God. Well, I just had a
big Twitter fight with Andrew Breitbart online
this week. Yeah.
>>LaFawn Bailey: Nice.
>>Aisha Tyler: I know. He's a d-bag. Um.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: They're so angry. Why are they
so angry? Do you ever think about that? Do
you ever think like do we seem that angry?
Do I seem, I don't know, I think I'm a pretty
happy person.
>>LaFawn Bailey: You're not angry.
>>Aisha Tyler: No, I'm not angry at all. I
love everybody. Um, I do a radio show on Tuesday
mornings and it's a syndicated show, the Stephanie
Miller Show, and they have a, she has a segment
called Tuesdays with Tyler every Tuesday morning,
and, I, yes, and I really will say, I
[clapping]
>>Aisha Tyler: Yeah, thank you. I, um, radio's
still around, what? Terrestrial radio? Where
does that come from? OK. So, I actually, I
am a progressive but I really do believe in
civil, civil civic debate. I think that you
can disagree with people in a thoughtful,
considered way and not resort to name calling.
I really do believe in that. I don't know
why I'm such a dumb idealist, but, um, I think
I can disagree with you and we can argue our
point. I'm confident enough in where I stand
to not feel like I have to force it down your
throat or call you names because we don't
agree. So, but, on that particular day, they
had played a quote from Rush Limbaugh that
was essentially the equivalent of that the
President is trying to turn America into a
middle-eastern fiefdom or something and, and
he likes to eat babies. It was something like
that. And all I said was, oh, catch on fire,
d-bag. And, ah,
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: Which isn't even the most artful
comeback, really, is it? I'm not proud of
it. If I'd given, if I'd had some time I could
have written something better, but then the
internet lit up and I quote, "Lefty, violent
lefty liberal slut, Aisha Tyler." I was like,
slut? What?
>>LaFawn Bailey: Ohhhh.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: Really? Why? Um, my husband
would be interested to find that out. The
husband that I've been with for 19, since
I was 19. I'm like I wish I was, I wish I
could be slutty in my house, that would be
great. Right? Like, hey you and me, more than
once a month? Let's do this. Um.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: Anybody else been married for
17 years, come on, this isn't news. Um.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: So, it was so, it went so extreme
so quickly and so lefty violent liberal slut
who eats babies, Aisha Tyler, wishes, wants,
wants to kill, wishes murder on Rush Limbaugh
by immolation. And I was like, what?
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: The worst I, the worst I wish
was that he would spontaneously combust, which
isn't even really like a, I think we've proved
on Snopes that that could never happen, so.
It's like if I said, "Suck an egg." Someone
would say, "She's trying to murder him with
salmonella." You know what I mean? Like I.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: There's no way. There's no
winning.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: So, Andrew Breitbart said,
"I hope Aisha Tyler blanks in a blank." And,
ah, and, ah, and then someone wrote, "You
should have Andrew Breitbart on your show."
And then I said, "I would love that if I thought
that Andrew Breitbart was the kind of man
brave enough to have a civil conversation
with someone he disagrees with."
>>LaFawn Bailey: Hmmm.
>>Aisha Tyler: Oh, zinger.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: And he has not responded, 'cause
he's a pussy.
[laughter and clapping]
>>Aisha Tyler: I'm sorry, you're gonna have
to bleep. This is gonna be, here's Aisha Tyler,
booooooooo. Thank you for coming to Google.
Goodnight.
[laughter]
>>LaFawn Bailey: One last question.
>>Male audience member 2: Hi, Aisha. My name's
Curtis.
>>Aisha Tyler: Hi Curtis.
>>Male audience member 2: So my question assumes
that as a comedian, social media has been
a big boon for you.
>>Aisha Tyler: I think so.
>>Male audience member 2: It seems like five
or six years ago, as long as you didn't steal
somebody else's material and didn't talk smack
about them unless they stole material, you
were done. But these days it seems like you,
as a comedian, might have an obligation to
cross promote everybody else's podcast and
book and show
>>Aisha Tyler: Hmmmm.
>>Male audience member 2: And tweets and on
and on and on and that other people, so other
people will do the same for you.
>>Aisha Tyler: Right.
>>Male audience member 2: Is that a correct
perception?
>>Aisha Tyler: You know I think that's really
very perceptive, very astute. Maybe I would
use different language and not so much talk
about obligation as opportunity, in that the
successful podcast community is actually relatively
small. There are obviously a jillion podcasts,
but the podcasts that are "winning" for lack
of a better word, thanks Charlie Sheen.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: Is, is very, for so many things
really, is very narrow and actually Chris
Hardwick said it best in that if one boat
rises in the podcast verse, which is also
his word, I don't want to say that I took
that, it's his word, we all rise. So if you
have a show that's successful, it really does
elevate all the other podcasts. And there
are, I'm sure there's some great ones that
no one has heard of, but the ones that are
at the top are generally pretty well produced
and pretty interesting. So, yeah, if you have
a friend who has got a show, I've never said,
"Hey, put me on your show and I'll put you
on my show." But mainly I've just called people
that I know or they've called me and you know,
I'm gonna do your show, why wouldn't, why
wouldn't we do that for each other, you know?
And there are shows that like, I just did
Sklarbro Country, which is a fantastic podcast,
it's a sports-oriented podcast, really well
produced. Way more like radio than my little
crappy thing that I do, but, ah. They, I just
was listening to their show and I tweeted,
"Oh my God, I'm listening to Sklarbro Country
and it's hilarious." And then they called
like three days later and said hey come on
the show. So there's that nice kind of supportive
thing. I think you want people who are talented
and funny to win and if you do them a favor
they want to do it back for you. So like I
just did Chris' show and he's coming on my
show in about a week and, and I think, I think
right now because it's still, it's, it's,
it's finally kind of getting some teeth, podcasting,
but it's still relatively new for the rest
of the world. I don't know what the numbers
are, but I feel like it's maybe 20 percent
of the country has downloaded or listened
to a podcast at some point. That's, I don't
know, I don't know what critical mass, I don't
know, does somebody have an algorithm in here?
Somebody?
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: Anybody at Google have an algorithm?
>>Aisha Tyler: For working out like what,
like when that's gonna be like a real number?
But I think, you know, again, you've got somebody
who's got a successful show, you go on their
show, that helps your show and vice versa.
And, and, so for me right now, 'cause I've
either done or I'm gonna do most of the big
podcasts, I just did The Nerdist, I did, Curly
just came on my show. I don't know if I'm
ever gonna do Mark's show. He's a shut-in
and an odd fellow. But you know if he asks,
I would do it. I would absolutely do it and
I would have him on if he wanted to come on
my show because I think it just, it helps
all of us and also I do one thing in the context
of my show. You know, my show is it's own
animal. I think the way that nerd, that, that
podcasts win is to really find a very clear,
a very clear path and approach for your show.
That's like, you know, people know this is
the experience I'm gonna have when I listen
to this podcast. And try to find something
that's definitive. So the experience you're
gonna have with me on my show is very different
than when I'm on someone else's show and vice
versa. You know what I mean? You're gonna
get a totally different experience and different
information from someone depending on the
context, so in that way I think they, they
complement. Right now the podcasts that are
doing well, that are interesting, they really
do complement each other and they're all kind
of parts of a pie.
>>Male audience member 2: Thank you.
>>Aisha Tyler: It was nice talking with you.
[laughter]
>>LaFawn Bailey: Thank you. I wanna make a
quick announcement. You are going to be at
Tres Agaves in San Francisco tomorrow.
>>Aisha Tyler: Just drinking, just drinking.
Really, anybody? Anybody?
>>LaFawn Bailey: Doing a Valencia fund raiser.
And from what I understand the show is sold
out.
>>Aisha Tyler: Yeah, the show is sold out,
but if I could just say one minute about it,
if you guys don't know about 826 Valencia,
this is a charity that Dave Eggers, the genius
writer, yes, one person reads books. That's
awesome. Two people, alright. Hey, and e-readers
are really killing us. Uh, so Dave Eggers
created this charity called 826 Valencia that
tutors underprivileged youth. Provides totally
free tutoring and also kind of mentors them
to help tutor other kids when they get a little
older. Teachers and all kinds of other people
volunteer, help kids with their reading and
writing skills. They put out this quarterly
publications where kids get their work published
in a book. If you know anything about Dave
Eggers in print McSweeney's, if any of you
have ever seen the McSweeney's Quarterly or
The Believer, he is an incredible believer,
not just in the concept of the printed word,
but in beautifully printed books and magazines.
Like everything he makes is so pretty. Like
I buy The Believer, I have a Believer from
three years ago. It's just sitting. I'm not
opening it. What? Spindle the spine? So he's
got this amazing charity, it's now I think
in five American cities. It's incredibly successful
and incredibly effective in terms of the amount
of money that's donated that's turned directly
into helping kids. And they have an associated
charity called ScholarMatch that finds scholarship
money for kids for talented high school kids
who have gotten into college and can't afford
to go. So these are kids that are in four-year,
they've gotten into a four-year school and
they can't. I don't if you. I don't even know
what it costs. What do you do to pay for school
now? Literally, sell blood? I don't even understand
how. I graduated with a mortgage and that
was 20 years ago. So I don't know how, I don't
know how kids do it. So this charity, a lot
of times the kids' goals is only a couple
of thousand dollars, that's all they need,
$2,000 or $3,000, so like a $20 donation or
a $50 donation is a big, big deal for ScholarMatch.
So if you want to, you know, go online and
visit the ScholarMatch.org site or visit 826
Valencia site and see what they're doing.
This is a guy who, you know, lost his parents
when he was young and then turned it into
a really, exploited his own tragedy for profit.
And uh, that's really, that's the American
way, isn't it? So and now he's doing stuff
for other kids and it's just, he's rah, he's
awesome. So the charity, the event's sold
out but you can still give and they'll be
other ones. Keep an eye out, 'cause ScholarMatch
does lots of fundraisers and they're great.
And Adam Savage is gonna be there. What? And
then we're gonna blow some stuff up.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: Know what? MythBusters is so
awesome.
>>LaFawn Bailey: Well, Aisha, on behalf of
Google, the Black Googler's network, and Women
at Google and Authors at Google, I want to
thank you very much for having this conversation
with us.
>>Aisha Tyler: It was really fun, thank you.
[clapping]
>>LaFawn Bailey: We have something for you.
>>Aisha Tyler: Super duper fun.
>>LaFawn Bailey: Lots of swag.
>>Aisha Tyler: Are you giving me the internet?
[laughter]
>>Female audience member #3: All secrets are
in the bag.
>>Aisha Tyler: It's amazing how small it is
when you put it in a bag.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: I bet there's some porn in
it.
[laughter]
>>Aisha Tyler: Thank you guys.
>>LaFawn Bailey: A really quick announcement,
Aisha brought some giveaways.
>>Aisha Tyler: Ooohhhh.
>>LaFawn Bailey: So if you look under your
chair and you have a yellow Post-It, you are
going to get a DVD or a book or something
or other, so.
[laughter]
>>LaFawn Bailey: If you have something there's
some chairs in the back, there might be something
under there.
>>Aisha Tyler: Thanks for seeing you guys,
that was super nice of you. Thank you. Bye.